ya hemos visto que cuando una neurona
está en su estado de reposo
hay una diferencia de voltaje a través
de la membrana en este diagrama de aquí
esta de aquí es la membrana esta es la
drá
nada esto de aquí es el in
dior
de la neurona y esto de aquí es el ex
y ahora y por supuesto esto también es
el ex
y ahora
si tienes un voltímetro midiendo la
diferencia de potencial a través de la
membrana si tomas este voltaje - este
voltaje de aquí la diferencia de voltaje
entre este y este obtendrás menos
digamos como hipótesis que medimos en
promedio alrededor de menos 70.000 y
volts
aquí están los mil volts y tenemos menos
70 aquí tenemos menos 70
- 70.000 y volts y lo haré de hecho para
ambas gráficas lo usaremos en ambas para
describir casos un poco diferentes o más
bien casos bastante diferentes tenemos
otro voltímetro aquí afuera en amarillo
que está un poco más lejos pero este
también registrará menos 70.000 volts
ahora hagamos que algo interesante
suceda digamos que por alguna razón la
membrana se vuelve permeable al sodio
así que el sodio empieza a fluir a
través de la membrana
y empieza a fluir al interior por dos
razones una es que es un guión positivo
es más positivo afuera que adentro así
que la carga positiva
entrar
y la otra razón para querer entrar es
porque hay una concentración mayor de
sodio en el exterior que en el interior
solo se disminuirá este gradiente de
concentración la razón por la cual
tenemos una mayor concentración de sodio
afuera que adentro y ya hemos visto que
es debido a la bomba sodio potasio pero
de todas maneras
tendrás este incremento en realidad
tendrás ese aumento de cargas positivas
fluyendo y entonces cuál será la
dinámica entonces dentro de la neurona
bien si tienes ahora todas estas cargas
positivas fluyendo las demás cargas
positivas en la neurona van a querer
alejarse de ellas querrán alejarse de
ellas las otras cargas positivas sólo
querrán alejarse
en ellas y esto no es sólo hacia la
derecha se dará en todas las direcciones
las cargas positivas intentarán alejarse
en todas las direcciones unas de las
otras está se moverá en esa dirección
y esa hará que ésta se mueva hacia esa
dirección ocasionará que esa se mueva
hacia esa dirección si dejas que
transcurra algo de tiempo como se verá
el voltaje en este voltímetro azul
después de algo de tiempo ya que más y
más cargas positivas intentarán alejarse
de estas de aquí la concentración de
esta parte llena de cargas positivas se
esparcirá y verás que el voltaje
empezará a incrementar verás que el
voltaje comenzará a crecer y cuando se
haya esparcido completamente entonces
regresará a algo parecido al
equilibrio y si avanzamos un poco más
hacia la derecha de la neurona pasará un
poco más de tiempo antes de que veas un
incremento en el voltaje
pero ya que estas cargas positivas se
expanden cada vez más en una distancia
mayor el efecto será más limitado no
verás un efecto tan grande como lo vimos
aquí y este tipo de propagación de creo
que deberíamos decir señal es llamada
propagación electro tónica déjame
escribir eso propagación electro tónica
esto es la pro
qué
acción
real
pero
niko potencial electro tónico y hay un
par de características aquí una es que
es pasiva esta parte que dibujamos aquí
esta no es la propagación electro tónica
la propagación electro tónica es lo que
sucede después de esto una vez que se
tiene esta alta concentración aquí el
hecho de que en unos momentos después
tendrás una concentración más alta de
cargas positivas aquí y unos momentos
después una concentración mayor aquí
este es un fenómeno pasivo esto de aquí
es
y también se disipa la señal se vuelve
cada vez más débil entre más te alejes
porque las cargas positivas cada vez
esparcen más así que es pasiva
y se disipa ahora volvamos a establecer
el caso pero agreguemos también canales
iónicos regulados por voltaje digamos
que esto que estoy dibujando aquí es un
canal de sodio regulado por voltaje y
este de aquí este es un
final de sodio
canal de sodio digamos que se abre se
abre a menos 55 mil volts
eso sería por aquí
ese valor indica cuando se abre
- 55 mil volts déjame dibujar ese umbral
ahí y digamos que cierra
sierra en
40 mil volts positivos cierra en 40 mil
volts justo ahí solo intento mostrar el
umbral
y digamos que también tenemos un canal
de potasio justo aquí
justo aquí este es un canal
y potasio
el potasio de fugas infames la verdadera
razón de que tengamos esta diferencia de
potencial a través de la membrana pero
este canal de potasio digamos que se
abre cuando éste se cierra así que se
abre
solo como hipótesis estos no serán los
números exactos pero te darán una idea
en 40 mil volts positivos y digamos que
se cierra
en menos 80 mil volts así que esa se
abre aquí arriba
y luego se cierra aquí abajo
ahora qué sucederá igual que como vimos
antes dejemos que nuestra carga positiva
fluya hacia adentro en el lado izquierdo
de esta membrana en la parte izquierda
de esta neurona podríamos decir y
después debido a la propagación electro
tónica un poco después verás que el
potencial a través de esta membrana
empezará a volverse menos negativo la
diferencia de potencial será menos
negativa tal como lo vimos aquí se
volverá menos negativa
pero no irá un poco hacia arriba y luego
bajará porque qué pasa cuando el
potencial alcanza en los menos 55.000
volts
bueno entonces accionar a la apertura de
este canal de sodio así que el canal de
sodio se abrirá porque el voltaje se
volvió lo suficientemente alto y
entonces el sodio volverá a fluir hacia
adentro otra vez
y qué es lo que hará eso
eso incrementará abruptamente el voltaje
se verá algo así seguirá fluyendo al
interior y el voltaje se volverá cada
vez más positivo porque recuerda que
esto estará fluyendo al interior por dos
razones una es que simplemente hay una
carga mayor es más positivo el exterior
que el interior así que irá a través del
gradiente de voltaje disminuirá el
gradiente de voltaje y también reducirá
el gradiente electro potencial pero
también hay una concentración mayor de
sodio aquí afuera que aquí adentro
debido a la bomba sodio potasio y
entonces también se quiere disminuir
este gradiente de concentración seguirá
fluyendo hasta el punto en el que no se
tenga gradiente de voltaje pero debido a
que el gradiente de concentración
seguirá fluyendo
pero luego cuando se llega a 40 mil
volts este canal se cerrará así que el
flujo se detendrá y también se abre el
canal de potasio y el canal de potasio
ahora el interior es más positivo que el
exterior por lo menos de manera local
aquí y ahora tendrás este guión de
potasio cargado positivamente queriendo
salir de este ambiente positivo y
entonces el voltaje se hará cada vez más
negativo irá más allá de lo neutral
porque el potasio querrá bajar
no sólo su gradiente de voltaje hará eso
mientras sea positivo en el interior y
negativo en el exterior o más positivo
en el interior que en el exterior pero
también quiere disminuir el gradiente de
concentración hay una mayor
concentración de potasio en el interior
que en el exterior debido a la bomba
sodio potasio así que el potasio solo
seguirá saliendo y saliendo
y luego al llegar a menos 80 mil volts
el canal de potasio se cierra y podemos
volver a nuestro estado de equilibrio
ahora por qué es esto interesante bueno
tenemos la propagación electro tónica
hasta este punto pero la señal solo
seguirá disipándose y disipándose si te
alejas lo suficiente será difícil notar
esa señal y entonces lo que esto hizo
esencialmente es solo estimular la señal
otra vez y ahora unos momentos después
si fueras a medir la diferencia de
potencial porque estas cargas intentan
alejarse unas de las otras
nuevamente tienen propagación electro
tónica si fueras a medir la diferencia
de potencial a través de la membrana
donde está este voltímetro amarillo
entonces tendrás dónde está el amarillo
antes sólo tenía una pequeña cresta pero
ahora tendrá una cresta bastante alta y
si de hecho tuvieras otro canal iónico
regulado por voltaje entonces eso se
estimularía otra vez entonces este tipo
de estímulo muy activo del voltaje esto
es llamado potencial de acción
sal
sión
podrías ver esto como la estimulación de
la señal la señal esparciéndose la
propagación electro tónica activas un
canal un canal regulado por voltaje y
entonces eso estimula la señal
nuevamente y como vemos la neurona usa
una combinación tal cual como la
describimos aquí para propagar una señal
para propagar la pasivamente pero luego
la estimula para que la señal pueda
cubrir distancias grandes